SPEAKER_00: safety should have been a backstop.
SPEAKER_00: The commission later criticized weak problem reporting, inadequate trend analysis, misrepresented criticality, and safety structures that did not give the concern enough independent force at the decisive points.
SPEAKER_00: People can care about safety while the way decisions are made still lets a warning arrive too late, too thin, or too resolved to change action.
SPEAKER_00: By launch morning, the warning had passed through hardware evidence, paperwork, meetings, waivers, charts, recommendation, caucus, and management acceptance.
SPEAKER_00: At the end of that route, launch was still open.
SPEAKER_00: at 11.38 a.m.
SPEAKER_00: Eastern Standard Time on January 28, 1986, Challenger launched from Kennedy Space Center.
SPEAKER_00: Within the first second, smoke appeared near the right aft field joint.
SPEAKER_00: The primary O-ring had not sealed the way it needed to seal.
SPEAKER_00: The secondary O-ring, affected by cold and joint movement, had not saved the joint in time.
SPEAKER_00: The smoke continued through roughly T plus two and a half seconds, then it disappeared.
SPEAKER_00: The commission considered that combustion residue may have temporarily sealed the breach.
SPEAKER_00: For a short time, the vehicle could look normal while the failure chain remained alive.
SPEAKER_00: That temporary quiet is one of the clearest details in the record.
SPEAKER_00: The physical system did what the organization had been doing for years.
SPEAKER_00: A sign of breach appeared, an explanation arrived, and flight continued.
SPEAKER_00: Around 58 to 59 seconds into flight, flame became visible again,
SPEAKER_00: Hot gas from the right booster began damaging surrounding structure, including the external tank area.
SPEAKER_00: At approximately 73 seconds, Challenger broke apart.
SPEAKER_00: Francis Dick Scobey, Michael Smith, Judith Resnick, Ellison Onizuka, Ronald McNair, Gregory Jarvis, and Krista McAuliffe were lost.
SPEAKER_00: The visible failure lasted seconds.
SPEAKER_00: The invisible one had been accumulating for years.
SPEAKER_00: What came next was the question every institution fears.
SPEAKER_00: How did this happen when the evidence already existed?
SPEAKER_00: President Reagan appointed the Rogers Commission, chaired by William Rogers.
SPEAKER_00: Richard Feynman was one of its members, and his independent work became part of the public memory of the investigation.
SPEAKER_00: The physical cause was direct, failure of the seal in the right booster's aft field joint, hot gas escaping, damage to the external tank area, and vehicle breakup.
SPEAKER_00: The commission did not stop at the physical cause,